madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans cette
édition la libération ce matin de mara
d'arad l'ancien jardinier maroc a
toujours clamé son innocence
il évoque sa réhabilitation l'état de
santé de jean pierre chevènement
l'extrême prudence des médecins un coma
réactif avec une amélioration
progressive de son état neurologique
polémique dans le verdon autour de la
construction d'une ligne à haute tension
qui devrait traverser l'un des sites les
plus visités de france pour célébrer le
centenaire de l'aviation exposition sur
les champs elysées d'une cinquantaine
d'appareils dont les plus anciens ont
été acheminés hier soir sur une immense
barge premières heures de liberté donc
pour omar haddad qui a quitté à la levée
d'écrou la centrale de muret après plus
de sept années de réclusion
l'ancien jardinier marocain bénéficie on
s'en souvient d'une grâce partielle de
jacques chirac quand 96 aujourd'hui omar
haddad qui a toujours clamé son
innocence veut continuer à se battre
pour obtenir sa réhabilitation
valeria rue mythe christophe la roque à
plus de sept ans comme un rat là dedans
ce moment ils tombent dans les bras de
son avocat
8h05 ce matin à la sortie de la prison
de muret omar raddad est un homme
heureux mais il est aussi un homme
stressé à l'extérieur des dizaines de
journalistes l'attendent pour recueillir
ses premiers mots
mais je ne suis pas très content avec et
qui me l'a déjà un manière grave j'ai je
soulèverai le congo monusco gros ça veut
dire que c'est la vérité
omar raddad est libre mais pour la
justice il n'est qu'un coupable en
liberté son innocence celle qui proclame
depuis toujours il l'a voudrait
officielle et reconnue
il a sa liberté aujourd'hui
maintenant il s'agit du restitution
et quand je pense vu quand je dis
restituer son honneur embarrasse les
restitue son honneur la justice
française c'est à aix en provence comme
un rat babel goûter sa première journée
de liberté
c'est la première fois qu'il revient sur
le meurtre de ghislaine marchal et sur
son arrestation à l'hôte a mûri ma
montée le photon a en marre mais tu sais
le premier questionné me dis pourquoi
t'as fait ça
qu'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai rien fait
elle m'a dit si il rembarre me tuer
c'est toi le tuer mais d'un marché
mouassa démarré comme ça
le jury m'a de la date du jour j va
passer à la cour d'assises est détaillé
et ses jets sous les bras c'est à
quitter sa famille pour ça ou un imam
malheureusement pour à la justice c'est
en publiant aujourd'hui bien sûr le
talent de vérité parce qu'aujourd'hui
même le souhait les brimer un mental ils
sont pas les bras à 100% parce que c'est
c'est quelque chose et de déchirer ma
vire de scierie mobile mise en forme
toute ma famille si quelque chose peut
pas en vivre avec ça bon assez il faut
la justice et comme le faisait voir omar
haddad dit n'attendre plus que cela
l'hypothétique révision de son procès
que maître vergès on se marrait bien des
c'est sous liberté conditionnelle que
l'ancien jardinier est sorti ce matin
revenons à présent sur ce qu'il convient
d'appeler ''l'affaire omar haddad
condamné à 18 ans de réclusion pour le
meurtre de ghislaine marchal en juin 91
un verdict qui avait suscité émotion et
doute le rappel des faits dominique
verdir filmé par hasard dans une prison
du sud de la france
omar raddad depuis sept ans il clame son
innocence depuis quatre ans il souhaite
la révision de son procès enquête
dirigée instruction bâclée procès
controversé mais une simple inscription
en lettres de sang omar m'a tuer
condamne le jardinier marocain à 18 ans
de réclusion criminelle pour la justice
la victime a désigné du bout des doigts
son assassin peu importe les
invraisemblances aucun indice matériel
relevé dans la villa de schiste and
marshall à mougins ne vient confirmer
l'accusation aucune empreinte des
relevés 40 intellectuels prennent la
défense d'omar raddad
j'ai tout de suite vu peut-être aussi
comme romancier à quel point tout était
invraisemblable je me suis mais pourquoi
est ce que dans une instruction
judiciaire ont fait disparaître des
preuves
pourquoi est-ce que à la demande de la
famille la justice accepte de d'assainir
et le corps de madame marchal le corps
de ghislaine marchal incinérés aucune
contre expertise n'était possible
les détectives eux continuent l'enquète
c'est d'abord l'apparition d'un second
au bar au maroc un ex-détenu innocente
le jardinier marocain
hier c'est un privé qui affirmait
connaître les vrais coupables des pistes
soient fantaisiste 68 plus sérieuse
les conclusions d'un expert en écriture
sollicité par l'avocat de la défense
maître vergès pour lui mala marshall
n'est pas l'auteur de l'inscription omar
m'a tuer je n'ai pas trouvé de forme
significative de forme typés qui
caractérise un écrit aussi bien danser
dans ces lettres du sens que dans les
de comparaison la certitude de l'expert
convaincra-t-elle la commission de
révision pour reconnaître ses erreurs la
justice exige des éléments nouveaux
ainsi la sphère 16 mecs la ferme hills
et thiennot ont été recalées en cinq ans
661 dossiers ont été présentés 15
seulement ont débouché sur une révision
l'état de santé de jean pierre
chevènement dans le coma depuis
maintenant plus de 48 heures les
médecins parlent d'une amélioration
progressive mais reste extrêmement
prudent nous dira dans un instant benoît
duquesne
mais d'abord cet après-midi les voeux de
rétablissement de jacques chirac qui
était en modèle en moldavie nous
écoutant le chef de l'état j'ai été
naturellement tenu informé dès mercredi
de l'accident de santé de monsieur
chevénement je ne peux que exprimé des
jeux très sincère naturellement de très
rapide et très complet rétablissement de
la santé de jeu chevènement et je
voudrais aussi naturellement exprimèrent
son épouse et aux siens mon amitié dans
cette épreuve mais je crois comprendre
que les médecins sont un peu plus
optimistes et nous retrouvons devant
l'hôpital du val-de-grâce benoît
duquesne où les médecins d'après le
dernier communiqué reste très prudent je
ne sais pas s'ils sont plus optimistes
dit le chef de l'état
mais c'est vrai qu'il reste très prudent
c'est vrai qu'en même temps ils disent
que l'état de santé de jean pierre
chevènement s'améliore doucement et
qu'en tout cas cette évolution est jugée
positive le coma est qualifié de plus en
plus réactifs autrement dit de moins en
moins profond c'est sans doute pour ça
qu ici les choses sont très calmes
depuis cet accident opératoire monsieur
chevénement d'euros soit quasiment pas
visite il a bien sûr sa femme qui reste
auprès de lui et puis on a vu en fin
d'après midi
monsieur jean jacques queyranne le
secrétaire d'état à l'outre-mer qui donc
assure l'intérim au ministère de
l'intérieur
et bien lui rendre une visite tout à
fait le symbolique mais pour le reste
donc pas de visite ici et je vous
propose tout de suite d'écoutés en quels
termes le médecin chef de l'hôpital ici
du val de grâce à lui ce deuxième
communiqué sur la santé
monsieur chevènement monsieur jean
pierre chevènement est toujours en coma
réactif mais présente une amélioration
progressive de son état neurologique
comme c'est le cas dans ces situations
nous avons également à traiter les
conséquences pénales notamment par une
bien nice et les conséquences hépatique
du show qu'il a subi
nous gardons la même prudence quant aux
pronostics
notre communiqué vous sera donné demain
dans l'après midi
donc vous voyez la prudence reste de
mise alors sur le pronostic vital est
bien les médecins se disent aujourd'hui
là aussi prudent mais en revanche ils ne
sont plus réservées c'était le terme
qu'ils employaient hier matin pour le
reste il s'agit bien sûr d'abord
maintenant de traiter les autres
conséquences de cet accident
d'anesthésiques anesthésique qui s'est
produit hier avant-hier aux conséquences
sur les reins et le foie de monsieur
chevènement et qu'on va savoir s'il y
aura d'autres séquelles après une sortie
de coma éventuel est bien là bien sûr il
est trop tôt pour se prononcer et
d'après les médecins les premiers
examens qui permettront de le dire c'est
à dire notamment évidemment un scanner
et bien ses premiers examens auront lieu
vers la fin de la semaine prochaine
merci jean jacques queyranne qui assure
donc l'intérim de jean pierre
chevènement a rencontré ce matin place
beauvau les principaux collaborateurs
jean-jack queyranne qui devrait prendre
en charge pour plusieurs semaines les
affaires courantes
reste à savoir ce qu'il adviendra des
dossiers clés que devait traiter le
ministre de l'intérieur arnaud beauté
durant l'intérim le fauteuil de jean
pierre chevènement restera vide à 9h30
ce matin
jean-jack queyranne a tenu à s'installer
dans un bureau voisin un symbole pour
bien rappeler qu'il n'est pas question
de succession s'agit d'alain terry je
souhaite très vivement que jean pierre
chevènement soit rapidement par mobile
et j'assumerai la continuité de l'action
gouvernementale dont les grandes
orientations
sont celles du pacte républicain le
premier ministre a exprimé c'est à dire
la sécurité publique
le respect de l'état de droit l'intérêt
général sous qu'attendent nos
concitoyens
jean-jack queyranne a déjà pris
connaissance des principaux dossiers
avec les membres du cabinet la corse les
sans papiers ou encore la fiscalité
commune
il assistera également à toutes les
réunions prévues de longue date
à l'exception des voyages à l'étranger
dans l'organigramme gouvernemental
jean-jack queyranne et délégué auprès du
ministre de l'intérieur le choix du
secrétaire d'état à l'outre-mer a été
avalisée par le président de la
république prend l'intérim
toutes les décisions importantes
devraient être différée avant de
connaître les conséquences exactes de
l'accident de jean pierre chevènement et
la durée de son rétablissement au canada
l'enquète sera longue et méticuleuse
pour déterminer les causes de la
catastrophe aérienne qui a coûté la vie
à 229 personnes sur place les recherches
ralenties par de fortes pluies se
concentre sur les boîtes noires dans les
heures qui viennent
les parents et proches des victimes
devraient arriver à halifax
un avion affrété spécialement par la
compagnie aérienne quitté ce matin la
suisse avec à son bord près de 300
personnes qui vont commencer leur
travail de deuil et maryse burgot 78
kilomètres carrés la zone de recherches
au large des côtes canadiennes est
immense
78 kilomètres carrés d'une mère
recouverte de débris les sauveteurs sens
qu'ils ne retrouveront plus de
survivants du vol de la swiss air sont
donc des corps des morceaux de carlingue
mais aussi des milliers d'objets qu'il
rassemble scrupuleusement des sacs des
jouets des chaussures des livres qui
racontent la vie de 229 hommes femmes et
enfants disparus mercredi à 22h25
lorsque l'avion s'est abîmé au large de
la nouvelle écosse les pêcheurs locaux
font eux aussi l'impossible pour
récupérer ces bribes de vie quand on
retrouve des chaussures et les biberons
de vbg nous ce n'est vraiment pas très
joli à voir
disparaître ce jour là n'était pas son
destin marc rosset joueur de tennis
suisse avait réservé une place dans cet
avion
au dernier moment il n'est pas parti de
vue à la télévision à l'aéroport de
genève
les familles et les amis des victimes
soit fort et je me sens vraiment triste
j'ai vraiment eu de la chance de ne pas
prendre ce vol le petit village de
peggy's cove d'où partent les sauveteurs
s'apprête à accueillir les familles des
victimes
pendant ce temps les enquêteurs essaient
de comprendre les boîtes noires n'ont
pas été retrouvées mêlées coûte des
échanges entre le pilote et la tour de
contrôle permettent de reconstituer les
dernières minutes du vol
22h14 le pilote signale calmement la
présence de fumée dans le cockpit
il demande à regagner l'aéroport le plus
proche onze minutes plus tard ce même
pilote lance un appel de détresse
l'appareil disparaît brutalement des
écrans radars ce soir les responsables
de swissair comme les enquêteurs refuse
de spéculer sur les causes de l'accident
on ne sait donc pas pourquoi 229
passagers sont morts dont un homme
johnattan man il s'est battu toute sa
vie au sein de l'organisation mondiale
de la santé pour la lutte contre le sida
il avait 51 ans et puis toujours au
canada un boeing 757 avec 225 personnes
à bord a dû effectuer aujourd'hui un
atterrissage d'urgence à terre-neuve
après que le pilote est indiqué qu'il y
avait de la fumée dans le cockpit se
chartered une compagnie canadienne
faisait route vers glasgow en ecosse la
violence est fort heureusement posé sans
problème et sans blesser en france
semaine de rentrée scolaire avec la
volonté affichée de ségolène royal de
maintenir des écoles en milieu rural
l'exemple de ces communes dans les roues
qui ont regroupé leurs élèves dans une
seule école seule façon de maintenir un
poste d'enseignement depuis 30 ans
maintenant le système fonctionne avec en
commun un service de ramassage scolaire
véronique gags l'yonne et parce qu'elle
pense
la tribu de moncuit possède quatre
enfants à son actif au total leur
éducation de 0 à 18 ans comptera plus de
deux millions cinq cent mille francs à
leurs parents fonder une famille un
investissement
elisabeth quatre heures jusqu'à cet âge
l'enfant coûte relativement peu
l'essentiel des dépenses les frais de
garde jusqu'à un tiers du budget je
raconte
difficile de calculer le coût en terme
de temps surtout pour les femmes sans
arrêt jaunissant seraient stressés par
les sorties la voiture les lits conduite
ceux du mal à comprendre que les des
mamans qui ont des enfants puissent
travailler
olivier neuf ans pour les 4 11 ans pas
de frais excessifs l'alimentation est le
premier poste des dépenses
si le premier enfant coûte plus cher que
le deuxième
la tendance s'inverse lors de la 3eme
naissance trop petit le logement est
changée et 85 % des mamans s'arrête de
travailler les enfants grandissent il
coûte alors plus cher les questions
vestimentaires ça prend beaucoup
d'importance quand on arrive dans la
zone des 14 15 ans ap lice pour une
fille surtout pour une future stéphanie
14 ans entre 11 et 15 ans les
adolescents doublent leur budget loisirs
jusqu'à 6000 francs par an pour dénivelé
moment où très pour décorer les
faussaires et vend ou alors pour aller
au cinéma
maëlys 16 ans à partir de 15 ans les
dépenses sont comparables à celles d'un
adulte mais trois jeunes sur cinq
restent chez leurs parents jusqu'à 25
ans je pense que je prendrai un studio
après le bac pour être plus pratique et
produit près de mon université mais ça
dépendra aussi à des prix parce que bon
si ça aussi c'est trop cher autant que
je reste chez moi quoi le coût d'un
enfant un calcul déterminant pour le
barème des allocations familiales
l'opération restait délicate difficile
d'estimer la rentabilité d'un sourire
vous l'aurez noté un petit problème
d'aversion technique le sujet que vous
venez de voir concernait le prix de
l'éducation d'un enfant qui était donc
une enquête de nos confrères du point
j'en viens maintenant à la semaine de
rentrée scolaire
avec je vous le disais il ya un instant
la volonté affichée de ségolène royal de
maintenir des écoles en milieu rural je
vous propose de suivre l'exemple de ces
communes dans l'hérault qui ont regroupé
leurs élèves dans une seule école seule
façon de maintenir en fait un poste
d'enseignement ça fonctionne depuis 30
ans le système fonctionne bien avec en
commun un service de ramassage scolaire
véronique gaglione et parce qu'elle
pense
réveil à 8h bastien et léa ne se lève
pas plutôt que leurs camarades de classe
pourtant ils ont un bus à prendre tout à
l'heure mais ce n'est plus tout à fait
l'omnibus qui desservait les campagnes
il y a quelques années
moi je sais que quand j'étais au lycée
ou au collège je parte à 7 heures le
matin je venais à cette heure le soir et
ça fait des journées longues pour faire
les devoirs le soir
ici la classe communal a fermé il ya
trente ans il n'y avait plus assez
d'enfants depuis la population de saint
jean de cuculles a doublé pour atteindre
380 habitants mais rebâtir une école
n'est pas du tout à l'ordre du jour il
est très difficile avec 50 enfants de
construire une école parce que ce sont
des arts j'ai complètement différent
nous avons je rappelle que sur 50
enfants nous en avons jeunes qui sont en
maternelle et 30 qui sont en primaire et
que ce nombre d'enfants est très
fluctuant en suivant les années et
suivant le nombre de personnes qui
viennent habiter sur village les enfants
de ce1 gens vont donc à l'école des
matelles à cinq kilomètres de là le
département finance le bus la mairie
l'accompagnatrice les parents ne paie
rien et les enfants sur mon cou gènes
des fois je mets à côté de moi j'ai des
copains et copines
alors c'est bien oui
avec 147 élèves l'école des matelles ne
se pose plus la question de sa survie
la fermeture a été évité de justesse
cependant il ya quelques années les élus
n'ont pas oublié il y avait une classe
unique aux matelles le en quelle année
c'est et je sais pas très bien mais je
pense que ça remonte à peu près une
trentaine d'années et à ce moment là on
a accueilli les enfants de saint jean
qui était un peu nos sauveurs et c'est
clair que bon ça nous a bien aidés à ce
moment là et depuis ça continue et donc
sans qu'on se pose sans se poser la
question
saint-jean continuera donc moyennant une
aide financière aux matelles a envoyé
ses élèves dans l'école voisine
mais le regroupement s'arrêtera là il
n'est pas question ici d'accueillir en
masse les enfants d'autres communes les
matelles veulent garder leur école
certes mais une petite école préservant
l'identité du village à moscou contre
toute attente la douma se donne deux
jours supplémentaires pour examiner la
candidature de tchernomirdine au poste
de premier ministre le pays depuis 12
jours sans gouvernement s'enfonce un peu
plus dans la crise
le premier ministre par intérim devant
les sénateurs ce matin promet une
dictature économique pour redresser le
pays alors que boris eltsine serait prêt
à accepter une diminution de ses
pouvoirs
mais paradoxalement l'homme du jour
n'était pas tchernomirdine mais bien le
très médiatique général y est belle en
qui de plus en plus de russes voient un
recours le reportage de dorothée
olliéric et didier da il est celui qu'on
attend pendant des heures pour le voir
ou seulement l'apercevoir lié bête c'est
d'abord une présence même quand il se
tait pour les russes désemparé il est
l'homme qui peut encore faire quelque
chose pour la russie l'homme qui dit ce
qu'il fait et qui fait ce qu'il dit et
général gebet premier ministre c'est
pour quand
ça n'est pas mon travail si elle vous
propose non dit non
qu'est-ce que je n'eus je dirais non je
ne crois plus en sept personnages et usé
et imprévisible et si le peuple vous le
demande
bien sûr que oui
il fume autant que l'autre général le
seul qui compte à ses yeux de gaulle
comme lui il se dit au dessus des partis
mieux si on a un mois un mois pour
sortir de la crise un mois seulement
parce que le 7 octobre ce sera la grève
dans tout le pays
la greffe totale aujourd'hui on peux
plus mentir au peuple plus leur faire
ses grands 10 kg aux yeux ils n'ont rien
à manger du riz anas m rien à mettre à
leurs enfants et ils n'ont pas été payés
depuis des mois le général qui a mis fin
à deux guerres civiles en moldavie en
tchétchénie les bed séduit aujourd'hui
au temps qu'il fait peur on république
démocratique du congo nos équipes
sentent dans la province du katanga du
côté des rebelles jusqu'à présent ce
sont les militaires qui mène l'offensive
mais les politiques tentent désormais de
faire entendre leur voix et d'expliquer
leurs positions à la population qui leur
étaient stiller en boussier fait l'objet
cela a quelque chose d'étrange voire de
surprenant pour un observateur étranger
300 soldats de l'armée congolaise fait
prisonnier la semaine dernière lors de
la prise de kalemie par les troupes
rebelles vont se rallier à la rébellion
en présence de lunda bululu ancien
premier ministre de mobutu et
responsable politique du rcd le
rassemblement congolais pour la
démocratie
ils se sont ralliés librement il ya
aussi ce qu après conquête un qui ne
pouvait bien faire qui se sont donc cela
donne deux plus jeunes y sont pas
résolues ménard et ses sens et sont nos
amis et alliés des gens à leur cause
c'est le souci permanent des
responsables politiques de la rébellion
discours aux soldats visite de politesse
au
de guerre rencontre avec des
fonctionnaires qui n'ont pas été payés
depuis des mois ou des décideurs
économiques partout ailleurs on
appellerait ça une campagne électorale
ici il s'agit d'expliquer ce qu'on fera
après la victoire tout le groupe que
nous avons reçues se sont librement
exprimer nous avons répondu à leurs
préoccupations
il ya des choses que nous ne pouvons pas
faire mais celle que nous pouvons faire
opérer le plus rapidement
mais ce langage politicien a du mal à
passer auprès de populations qui ont
suivi deux guerres en deux ans ou non
plus sur la réconciliation
ok on passe à table de négociations et
que l'inflation devienne la vie normale
parce que nous malgré les appels et les
exhortations le meeting organisé dans
l'après midi par le rcd ne rassemblera
pas plus de 2000 personnes très encadrés
par des dizaines de soldats en armes qui
empêcheront tout mouvement de foule
lunda bululu viendra y parler de
démocratie de liberté de corruption de
tribalisme les mêmes mots avaient été
employés il ya deux ans par laurent
désiré kabila en faisant sa révolution
cette fois ci c'est plus difficile les
gens ne sont pas dupes les mythiques
comme c'est lé papier scep a bien fait
puisque nous sommes démocrates ne sont
pas celles vie démocratique c'est un
problème qui doit se passer librement
mais vu la qualité marquante les comptes
rico par ses tournées de promotion
baptisée prise de contact les
responsables du rcd façade politique de
la rébellion
essaye de faire connaître leur mouvement
un mouvement qui pour l'instant manque
totalement de soutien populaire
en tanzanie le tribunal pénal
international pour le rwanda a prononcé
aujourd'hui sa première condamnation
l'ancien premier ministre rwandais été
condamné à la perpétuité pour sa
participation au génocide contre les
tutsi en 94
la peine maximale malgré les aveux du
premier ministre qui a décidé de faire
appel
bill clinton à d'ubs l'a rappelé son
attachement à la paix en ulster le
président américain rattrapé par la
sphère levinsky s'est dit pour la
première fois profondément désolé pour
cette relation inappropriée pour
laquelle bill clinton se dit
indéfendable retournant à présent sur la
catastrophe aérienne à halifax je
rejoins en direct dominique derda la
liaison est rétabli aujourd'hui on
connaît à peu près mot pour mot les
conversations entre le pilote de l'avion
et la tour de contrôle
un échange qui a duré de longues minutes
et qui donne peut-être quelques
indications sur le déroulement de
l'accident
oui on connaît maintenant grâce à ces
enregistrements qui ont été rendus
publics ici cet après midi avec plus de
précision effectivement le déroulement
de ce vol pendant les quarante quatre
premières minutes
tout se passe comme comme d'habitude
tout se passe normalement l'avion prend
de l'altitude il remonte le long de la
côte est des états unis
mais à 22h15 ours zimmerman le pilote un
pilote expérimenté un instructeur lance
un premier message ce n'est pas encore
un message de détresse est un message
salaire pour signaler une anomalie de la
fumée qui s'élève du poste de pilotage
il décide alors de tenter de se
rapprocher de boston pour apte pour
faire un atterrissage d'urgence
finalement pour une raison que l'on
ignore encore à l'heure actuelle il
continue sa route vers halifax mais dix
minutes plus tard cette fois il en
devient un message de détresse
isa il entame alors les procédures
normales qui sont de baisser de
descendre de perdre de l'altitude il
passe de dix mille à deux mille cinq
cents mètres il
reid les réservoirs de son appareil en
tout cas en partie et ils essayent de se
rapprocher à la dernière de se
rapprocher de l'aéroport d'halifax
ce que l'on sait c'est qu'évidemment il
n'y arrivera jamais ce que l'on sait
c'est que les passagers ont suivi eux
aussi minute par minute et cette
descente
parce que les corps que l'on a retrouvés
dans la mer derrière moi ces corps
mutilés portaient pour la plupart des
gilets de sauvetage qui veut dire que
ils n'ont rien ils n'ont rien loupé de
la mort certaine qui les attendait mais
les ses passagers qui sont morts leurs
parents leurs familles vont bientôt
arriver dans quelques minutes ici elle
elle non plus ces familles n'ont plus
aucun espoir évidemment parce que les
recherches ont été interrompues ce matin
ce qu'elle espère ces familles sans
doute c'est que l'on retrouve vite
la boîte noire qui permettra de savoir
non pas minute par minute ce qui s'est
passé mais pourquoi
de la fumée s'est dégagée du poste de
pilotage merci et dominique derda de ces
précisions
jacques chirac en moldavie promet
l'appui politique et économique de la
france
reportage véronique syntonisent jean
cornu
ça pouvait être dansons la capucine met
à la mode moldave la moldavie que pour
la première fois depuis son indépendance
il ya quatre ans à chef d'état étranger
et qui sinon la capitale de ce petit
pays de 4 millions et demi d'habitants
coincée entre la roumanie et l'ukraine
fait la fête à son hôte
ici la situation économique est
difficile
la moldavie rêve donc de se rapprocher
de l'europe son premier bailleur de
fonds et elle compte bien sûr la visite
de jacques chirac pour l'aider dans ce
processus
cet après midi le grand amphithéâtre du
palais national était comble fierté et
enthousiasme
exprimé en français saisis les larmes
aux yeux à dire que les suppléments
romantique comme ça mais j'ai été plus
touchés par cette visite c'est un grand
pas pour notre pays d'entrée et de
d'être dans l'hérault coup comme dans sa
maison et jacques chirac ne déçoit pas
l'attendre
la participation de la moldavie à
l'europe
c'est une participation total cède la
moldavie qui prend sa place à la table
de famille et pour les jeunes la france
c'est aussi maintenant le foot je veux
dire je suis toujours assez satisfait
quand on me parle de la coupe du monde
encore un peu et je vais penser que j'ai
eu moi même joué sur le terrain
sur le fond jacques chirac a donc tenu
le même discours en moldavie et en
ukraine
la france aidera ces deux pays à
s'associer à l'europe mais pas question
pour autant d'intégration sondage
politique à paraître demain dans le
figaro magazine la cote de jacques
chirac et de lionel jospin en très
légère baisse par rapport au mois
dernier le chef de l'état perd trois
points avec 56% d'opinions positives le
premier ministre avec 70% d'opinions
favorables perd lui 1 point et puis
concernant le procès en belgique agusta
d'assaut cette information l'industriel
français serge dassault vient d'obtenir
l'autorisation de la cour de cassation
de ne pas assister à l'audience lundi en
raison de l'ouverture ce jour là d'un
salon aéronautique international en
france dans le verdon la polémique
autour de la construction d'une ligne df
à haute tension qui doit traverser de
part en part l'un des sites les plus
remarquables de france une commission
d'experts a rendu son rapport il ya
quelques semaines
nouvel épisode ces jours ci puisque la
population devra se prononcer sur la
construction de cette ligne à haute
tension sur place reportage de jacques
cardoze une plaie une cicatrice pour
l'environnement l'autoroute électrique
une ligne à très haute tension en plein
verdon 400 mille volts qui doivent
remplacer les deux lignes déjà
existantes
une polémique oppose l'edf d'une part
aux associations élus locaux d'autre
part
faut-il la construire vieille question
toujours pas tranché pour un vieux
dossier qui date du début des années 80
le juridique et df ne passera jamais sur
le werder nous allons mettre tout en
place
que ce soit des batailles sur le terrain
que ce soit juridiquement devant le
conseil d'état ne formulent sorte qu'edf
ne pas se plus sur le werder ce site a
été trop sacrifier d'hommes qu'est ce
que je dit apolitique d'acheter de l'eau
froide sacrifié selon les associations
par la construction de cinq barrages
hydroélectriques le verdon a le
sentiment d'avoir déjà payé et puis la
construction de cette ligne pourrait
avoir des conséquences néfastes sur
l'économie touristique
il se rappelle qu'il s'agit quand même
du deuxième canyon le plus fréquenté en
terme de population après le canyon
du colorado je pense qu'il s'agit là
d'un phare au niveau national au niveau
international nous avons compté sur une
année le passage de plus d'un million de
personnes
c'est quand même un signe révélateur de
la notoriété du site
et lorsqu'on sait qu'on a inscrit en
lettres d'or dans la charte le paysage
comme thème fondamental
je crois que les élus ne comprendraient
pas quant à la population elle accepte
mal les arguments avancés
edf insiste sur des risques importants
de délestage et de sécurité dans la
région
c'est parce qu'il y avait un
compréhension qu'un débat public a eu
lieu six mois de réunions avec les
habitants des communes concernées
six mois qui apparemment n'ont pas suffi
à faire et jouez déjà alors c'est même
pas la peine de faire de reportage
60 c'est déjà joué un peu semblant de
faire parler des écolos mais bon le
france que l'afer est joué
déjà depuis longtemps un débat public
tellement public qu'il a été envoyé à
tous les habitants de la région
les conclusions du rapport contenues
dans ces enveloppes seront connues de
tous
une opération entièrement financée par
edf le rapport souligne qu'il existe des
solutions alternatives et préconise la
construction de nouvelles centrales
une solution qui coûterait trop cher
selon edf il frappait quatre missions de
service technique c'est d'alimenter
partout en france avec les conditions de
qualité de sécurité mais aussi au
moindre coût et nous devons proposer aux
pouvoirs publics une solution qui soit
conforme à cette mission un look c'est
aux pouvoirs publics qu'il appartient de
décider quelle est la solution qui sera
mise en après plusieurs années de
discussions retour au point de départ
la décision reste politique c'est le
gouvernement qui va devoir choisir entre
une ligne électrique et deux centrales
thermiques
dans tous les cas de figure
entre deux formes de pollution la
rentrée de l'équipe de france de
football pour son match demain en
islande comptant pour les éliminatoires
de l'euro 2000 les bleus à nouveau roi
du stade peut-être alexandre kara
nathalie gallet discret
lorsqu'on est champion du monde c'est
toujours difficile de passer inaperçu
même dans un petit pays comme l'islande
il y à des caméras et des stylos qui
vous guette à l'arrivée c'est la rançon
de la gloire
c'est à dire bien peu de chose en
comparaison d'un titre planétaire pour
les anciens combattants du mondial c'est
l'heure des retrouvailles
c'est vrai que ça fait plaisir de
retrouver tout le monde de retrouver
cette ambiance qui n'existait pas du
monde mais bon ça en islande ils sont 14
champion du monde sur 18 sélectionnés
pour les bleus c'est le retour dans une
phase éliminatoire le genre de
formalités que depuis trois ans on avait
un peu oublié depuis il ya des choses
qui ont changé
les tricolores ont réussi leur première
étoile sur le maillot c'est une petite
broderie mais pour les bleus c'est un
grand bonheur
ça représente beaucoup et surtout du
maudit que cette étoile là étaient
brodés et que moi j'ai un petit bout de
de l'étoile qui m'appartient et puisque
j'ai fait partie de ceux qui ont fait
cette histoire donc c'est une grande
grande fierté
même si le remplacement d'aimé jacquet
par roger lemerre ressemble plus à une
continuité qui est une véritable
succession il n'empêche que la page du
mondial et bien tournée l'ambition des
bleus c'est aujourd'hui et demain l'euro
2000 et comme sous l'ère jacquet ou
respectent eux-mêmes l'adversaire le
plus modeste
on sait que ce sera difficile mais on
ose espérer on ne vient pas en islande
pour gagner comme ça facilement la fleur
au fusil ça c'est une chose qui est
certaine et les gens sont avertis pour
les bleus les vacances sont bien finies
d'ici à octobre 99 face à l'islande la
russie l'ukraine
l'andorre et l'arménie ils devront
prouver qu'ils sont bien des champions
pour espérer après s'être offerts le
monde
s'offrir l'europe pour célébrer
dignement un siècle d'aviation une
cinquantaine d'appareils des vieux
coucous du début du siècle jusqu'aux
chasseurs d'aujourd'hui seront exposés
sur les champs elysées à partir de la
semaine prochaine
dès cette nuit une dizaine de ses avions
des tout débuts ont été acheminés sur
une immense barge qui remontait la seine
patrice pollet valérie creed ans s'est
tenue en se promenant dans paris il y
avait de quoi rester bouche bée devant
cette vision celle d'avions sortant de
la cale d'une péniche est ensuite
déposée sur le pont de l'alma paname
transformer en aérodrome
voilà ce qui a excité la curiosité des
rares badauds présents pendant
l'opération
on en voit sur impôts donc c'est nous
intrigue donc on vient voir il n'y a pas
de mots c'est à le voir là ici sur le
sur le pont de l'alma c'est c'est
quelque chose d'absolument on peut dire
que des banalités tellement ça ça prend
à la gorge
débarqué rive gauche l'escadrille est
ensuite passée rive droite
une mission délicate qui imposait un
passage en rase-mottes sur le pont
alexandre iii une grandiose traversée de
paris vers 4 heures
l'atterrissage se dérouler en douceur
sur les champs elysées lieu de
l'exposition
les pilotes d'air france et les pilotes
de l'armée qui sont partenaires seront
là pour accueillir les gens en leur
disant je vole là dessus et voilà
pourquoi et comment ça marche j'ai volé
là dessus pour les anciens voilà
pourquoi et comment ça marchait
pendant deux semaines une cinquantaine
de machines symbole des ailes françaises
seront présentes et chasseurs
bombardiers jaguar hélicoptères de
combat l'occasion unique d'admirer aussi
le rafale avant qu'il ne redécolle
c'est la fin de cette édition je vous
rappelle les principaux titres la
libération ce matin de marc haddad
l'ancien jardinier marocain toujours
clamé son innocence
il évoque sa réhabilitation l'état de
santé de jean pierre chevènement
l'extrême prudence des médecins un coma
réactif avec une amélioration
progressive de son état neurologique
indique un communiqué dans un instant la
météo et isabelle martinez suivi du
point route de valérie maurice demain
dans thé ou café catherine ceylac pour
sa rentrée reçoit jean claude gaudin
maire de marseille
je vous retrouve demain dès 13h merci de
votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2
ce